Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
hoy nos acompaña la actriz española musa
de almodóvar Rosi de Palma que acaba de
ser nombrada embajadora de buena
voluntad para la diversidad cultural del
UNESCO Rossi de Palma Gracias por esta
entrevista con Francia 24 embajadora de
buena voluntad del UNESCO que sientes y
Qué significa me siento la verdad muy
presumida que yo soy de difícil
impresionar eh pero sí me siento como
bueno
como se dice en inglés que estás como
hoy no me lo puedo creer y por un lado
bueno pues es un honor un privilegio una
responsabilidad también pero es muy
feliz me siento feliz de pertenecer a
esta este planeta UNESCO que ya suele
Entrar en este lugar ya te hace sentir
que perteneces a una humanidad
mezclada rica en culturas y que valora
todo todo lo bueno que tenemos
el momento de tu carrera llega este
reconocimiento lo podemos llamar bueno
reconocimiento es como casi un encargo
también no O sea hay un reconocimiento
implícito de pensar que yo puedo ser
adecuada para ser embajadora de la
diversidad cultural embajadora de buena
voluntad bueno voluntad la tengo toda y
espero poderles servir y servir a todos
servirnos a todos luego Es verdad que no
tengo como nunca he sido cardíarista
Entonces no tengo como mi carrera estos
conceptos no los tengo soy un artista
que hago pues de la vida donde venir
poético y no pienso en carrera o no sé
qué pero sí me siento me siento
privilegiada de tener este
reconocimiento porque creo que me va a
poder legitimizar de alguna manera para
ayudar Mejor y para para colaborar y
Resaltar cosas en otra frecuencia un
poco más elevada no O sea para la
necesidad de sentirme útil No que todo
artista social como soy yo que soy un
artista con base social pues me interesa
sentirme útil No ya ya he hecho Bueno
por ejemplo yo soy madrina de o África
que ayuda a los niños o también con
Open Arms que conoce el drama de
mediterráneo salvavidas colaboró muchas
cosas pero quizá con esta embajaduría
pues me legitima para ser más influyente
en un nivel un poco más que yo me haga
sentir que estoy siendo más útil No
diversidad justamente el comunicado de
prensa de la UNESCO dice que desde joven
denunciaste la tiranía de la mirada de
los demás sé que sufriste de bullying de
acoso escolar cuando era pequeña esa
experiencia no sé si nos la puedes
compartir y eso cómo te puede ayudar en
este puesto justamente Para empoderar
algunas personas quizás no tengo que
reconocer que en aquella época no
existía la palabra bullying no no éramos
Ay me han hecho bullying no no teníamos
ese esa nomenclatura ni ese parámetro
pero
si cuento esto no es para darme
importancia a mí que no tiene ningún o
sea yo pude sufrir un poco el trauma de
los niños de la crueldad de los del
mundo de los niños y adolescentes pero
no me siento víctima nunca me he sentido
víctima eh yo creo que primero de todo
no sentirse víctima ayuda mucho porque
si tu desgracia o tu felicidad depende
de nosotros pues al final estás como
maniatada Entonces yo nunca me sentí
víctima al contrario cogí todo esto que
este acoso que podía sufrir
por un apéndice nasal que a mí nunca me
molestó lo cogí como o casi como si
fuera una especie de escudo
y que mientras la gente se quedaba
parapetada y yo podía evolucionar y va a
profundizar en la psicología del ser
humano yo digo cómo me pueden culpar a
mí por algo que yo no he elegido Y eso
extrapolándolo pues lo podemos llevar a
una morfología de una persona que es
grande otro que es muy pequeño uno que
es muy delgado otro que es muy gordo y
el color de la piel o sea algo que tú no
has elegido cómo te pueden culpabilizar
de ello no Entonces me dio toda esta
sensación dice
psicológicamente aprendí mucho de este
hándicap a priori que para mí no era un
hándicap pero era un poco la mirada del
otro no entonces uno no es responsable
de la mirada del otro pero sí
me ayudó a reflexionar mucho de esto de
qué Matiz como podemos culpabilizar a
alguien por algo que no nadie ha elegido
no en la lotería de la vida en la
lotería de los cuerpos en la lotería de
geográficamente donde naces que puede
ser muy Injusto mira ahora las mujeres
hubiéramos nacido ahí ahora mismo
estaríamos en esa Revolución intentando
que ser libres no tú que eres chilena yo
española que hemos vivido dictaduras muy
fuertes sabemos lo que se está bajo bajo
bajo una oscuridad así como lleva
ese Irán no entonces todo eso yo creo
que ha sido una riqueza para mí me ayuda
a profundizar y a comprender Por qué los
seres humanos a veces nos perdemos en
esas diferencias que no tienen ningún
sentido y de ahí ya vienen los
nacionalismos y todas las cosas
terribles no hablaba del color de piel
tu participas toda una campaña y ya con
un desconocierto contra el racismo pero
en este nuevo puesto te dan tres temas
que tienes que tratar el estatuto del
artista Tú sabes lo que es ser artista
te sientes una beneficiada porque tengo
la impresión de que nunca te falta
trabajo que estás cada día haciendo mil
cosas a la vez y además contenta y feliz
guapa y juvenil
Entonces crees que eres beneficiada o
que eres privilegiada En comparación con
otra gente que quizás él es más difícil
yo primero tengo que reconocer mi
ignorancia en muchos temas porque yo al
ser artista autodidacta no haber tenido
una formación ortodoxa vamos a decir y
ser un poco electrón libre tengo mis
aciertos gracias a eso pero también
tengo mis fallos y mis
deficiencias de base no de formación
dijéramos no Por ejemplo yo hago
esculturas pero nunca estudié bellas
artes entonces a veces no sé qué tipo de
materiales puedo usar que y esto también
te lo hablo sobre el estatuto del
artista yo ahora como artista embajadora
de la UNESCO me voy a informar muchísimo
porque sé que hay muchas injusticias y a
nivel de la de la peritoriedad que tiene
este trabajo que puedes trabajar mucho
como tú dices a mí no me falta pero
pueden neutros que pasan épocas de mucho
trabajo épocas que trabajan muy poco
por ejemplo no sé me voy a informar en
cada gobierno Cómo sucede en España por
ejemplo la declaración de los artistas
es anual como la de todos los ciudadanos
y que ocurre que por ejemplo un artista
un año puede tener mucho trabajo y el
año siguiente no entonces creo que aquí
en Francia es cada tres años la
fiscalidad Entonces quiero enterarme
todo esto para hablar ahora que voy a
ser embajadora me voy a estudiar bien
pero a nivel dijéramos
cómo te podría decir casi metafórico
todos somos artistas yo creo que todo
ser humano tiene una capacidad artística
Yo no creo en la vanidad del artista de
que se cree un genio por haber compuesto
una sinfonía o por haber creado esto por
haber hecho el otro yo creo que somos
todos vehículos del arte pero que el
arte no nos pertenece o sea somos
transmisores y cuanto menos ego tienes o
menos importancia te das más más
ridículas
esa fascinación pero por ejemplo tú
puedes tener una idea maravillosa genial
no llevarla a cabo y otra persona en
otro lugar del mundo se le puede ocurrir
y la hace tangible y no es que te haya
robado esa idea ni nada sino que todo
está ahí en ese ente colectivo y luego
lo que sí nos podemos van a gloriar o
estar orgullosos es de por ejemplo un
director de cine o una directora A lo
mejor pasa cuatro años o cinco o seis
para conseguir 7 inclusive para
conseguir
realizar una película no entre que con
Buscar la financiación entre que haces
posible esa perseverancia esa voluntad
de crear algo de vincular un mensaje
todo eso sí es algo de que puedes decir
lo hecho posible pero la genialidad de
la obra en sí o la No genialidad no es
algo que el artista es como lo de Ulises
y La Ilíada Lo importante es el camino
hacia ítacanos bonito o es decepcionante
otro tema dentro de esta de este rol de
embajadora será la igualdad hombre o
mujer te has sentido alguna discriminada
por ser mujer en tu trabajo Yo nunca me
he sentido discriminada porque yo
siempre he dicho si los derechos son
míos
y me pertenecen para que los voy a pedir
los cojo directamente Entonces cuando
eres osada Yo soy un poco con profesión
osada me gusta usar Entonces cuando eres
rosada pues no estás esperando a que te
validen tú agarras lo primero que te
parece que te corresponde y nunca me he
sentido discriminada Pero porque he sido
con esta capacidad de decir Bueno pues o
lo que tú decías Pero no queréis taza
taza y media no os gusta mi nariz Pues
ahora Vais a terminar en todos lados y
fotografiado hasta la saciedad pero en
el cuestión hombre y mujer yo lo único
que creo que es necesario es que los
salarios se equiparen por el mismo
trabajo el mismo salario
Incluso en el cine en el teatro
yo creo que ya no puede ser una
excepción y que ya tendría que ser algo
que los gobiernos
impusieran ya de manera categórica no
pero luego no me gusta tampoco en el
mundo artístico hacer mucho la
diferencia entre hombre mujer en el
sentido
que un artista pues es un artista sea
hombre mujer esa capacidad de vehicular
cosas hermosas y en el hecho de la
igualdad mujer y hombre pues eso yo creo
que los salarios luego las mujeres ya
estamos en un punto de no retorno de
conocernos a nosotros mismas y de saber
lo que queremos hemos usado ese espejo
del hombre porque ha sido necesario para
conseguir las mismas cosas que la
sociedad no nos daba pero ahora estamos
en un punto de más introspectivo yo creo
que las mujeres y de descubrimiento de
nosotras tu compromiso con la ong
operance que trabaja en el tema
migratorio También trabajas con esta ong
en África que ayuda
qué otras causas te mueven en este
momento es que hay muchas pero sobre
todo estas cosas que nos hacen sufrir
tanto a los humanos y que no tiene
ningún sentido de existir no el problema
migratorio las muertes en el
Mediterráneo es algo que siempre me han
angustiado porque una persona por nacer
en un sitio puede viajar a cualquier
sitio del mundo y otro les impuesto que
no porque
todas las
materias primas y energías tantas cosas
que
de alguna manera occidente
se ha beneficiado que no sabe devolver o
que encima se cree que quieres como era
omnipresente como lo que hacemos con los
animales con la naturaleza es muy
importante también todo el problema del
cambio climático Y cómo el ser humano no
se va a cuidar la naturaleza y la
conciencia que tenemos que desarrollar
constantemente sobre esto el agua que va
a ser un problema muy grande también en
los años venideros Bueno ahora estamos
con todo este problema del armamento lo
nuclear que mejor no tocarlo este tema
hoy porque vivimos en un mundo que está
como como si estuviéramos sentados en
una caja de Pandora que no sabemos lo
que va a suceder no entonces esa
incertidumbre después de una pandemia
después de todo son épocas
Bueno pues eso que tenemos que tener esa
que quizás sean muy terribles Pero
quizás también sean detonadoras de otro
nivel más elevado de consciencia donde
nos demos cuenta de lo que estamos
haciendo y seamos todos más
autoresponsables no muchas gracias
Rosita
Muchas gracias Un placer de verdad
ustedes continúen con la programación
habitual de nuestra cadena